Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power. Who seeks it, who seizes it, and how easily, can all slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they proclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。没错，就是 restishistory.com。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。历史一直是一个关于权力的故事。谁在寻求权力，谁在攫取权力，以及权力如何轻易地溜走。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广袤的土地，自封为神的宠儿，然而他们的帝国最终还是土崩瓦解了。
It is easier to conquer than it is to control. Hive takes a different approach. It puts power where it belongs in your hands. They started with smart thermostats, and they've now gone much further. Solar panels, heat pumps, EV charges, all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone,
征服容易，统治难。Hive 采取了不同的方法。它将权力归还给它应在的地方——你的手中。他们从智能恒温器起家，如今已走得更远。太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电桩，所有这些设备协同工作，让你能以自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋权。查看你的手机，
seeing the heating's on, the car's charging, and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit hive.com. to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive compatible with selected technology. High above all a cloth of state was spread, and a rich throne as bright as sunny day,
看到暖气开着，汽车正在充电，屋顶上的太阳能板也在静静地为你创造价值。凯撒当年可没法给他的战车充电，但我相信他一定会钦佩这种效率。访问 hive.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 兼容特定技术。在一切之上，铺着一块华丽的帷幔，还有一张如艳阳般明亮的宝座，
on which there sat most brave embellished with royal robes and gorgeous array, a maiden queen that shone as titans ray in glistering gold and peerless precious stone. So that was the great poem, The Fairy Queen by Edmund Spencer, and he is really laying it on, isn't he, Tom, in praise of perhaps the greatest of all English monarchs, Elizabeth the first. Gloria Anna, as he calls her in the poem, a queen famous for her willpower, her courage, her beautiful. and her dedication to England and England's glory. Yeah, well, I mean, the name Gloria Anna suggests it, that this is a queen who's all about glory. You know, that is absolutely the image that she still has today, and it derives from poems like
上面坐着一位极其勇敢、身着皇家礼服和华丽盛装的少女女王，她如泰坦的光芒般闪耀，身披闪烁的金饰和无与伦比的宝石。这就是埃德蒙·斯宾塞的伟大诗作《仙后》，汤姆，他确实在极力赞美这位或许是英国历史上最伟大的君主——伊丽莎白一世，不是吗？正如他在诗中所称的“格洛丽安娜”（Gloria Anna），一位以意志力、勇气、美丽以及对英格兰及其荣耀的奉献而闻名的女王。是的，我的意思是，“格洛丽安娜”这个名字本身就暗示了这一点，这位女王的一切都与荣耀有关。你知道，这绝对是她至今仍拥有的形象，而这源于像
the fairy queen. Elizabethan propaganda was incredible. And we would associate her with, I guess, a kind of golden age, the spring flowering of English literature, so Shakespeare and Spencer, of course, and Marlowe, and the exploration of the globe by English sea dogs, so Sir Francis Drake and Sir Walter Raleigh, and of course, the defeat in 1588 of the Spanish Armada. And I guess that that is a triumph for English arms that ranks in the national mythology alongside, I guess, Trafalgar, which we've just been doing recently, and the Battle of Britain, wouldn't you say? Yes. I mean, it's kind of, up there in the pantheon. She's one of the genuinely titanic figures of English history. I mean,
《仙后》这样的诗作。伊丽莎白时代的宣传真是令人难以置信。我们会把她与某种黄金时代联系在一起，比如英国文学的春季繁荣，也就是莎士比亚、斯宾塞、马洛，以及英国海盗对全球的探索，比如弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士和沃尔特·罗利爵士，当然还有 1588 年对西班牙无敌舰队的击败。我想，这在民族神话中是一场与特拉法尔加海战（我们最近刚讲过）和不列颠战役并列的英军胜利，你觉得呢？是的。我的意思是，它在万神殿中占有一席之地。她是英国历史上真正泰坦级的人物之一。我的意思是，
the comparison with Nelson and Churchill is a good one because in each of those cases, they define themselves against what appears to be an overwhelming foreign adversary with a threat of invasion. They do, yes. And more than that, they like Nelson, like Churchill, Elizabeth finds the words of defiance that inspire her people and which I think still kind of have a power to stir the blood of a patriotic Englishman today. And Dominic, I see you smiling as I say that. So she has this thrilling peroration. I know I have the body of a weak and feeble woman, but I have the heart and stomach of a king and of a king of England too. And think foul scorn that Parma or Spain or any Prince of Europe should dare to invade the borders of my realm. And so she is speaking
与纳尔逊和丘吉尔的比较很恰当，因为在每一个案例中，他们都是在面对看似压倒性的外国对手和入侵威胁时定义了自己。确实如此。不仅如此，像纳尔逊和丘吉尔一样，伊丽莎白找到了激励她人民的抗争之词，我认为这些话至今仍有一种能激起爱国英国人热血的力量。多米尼克，我这么说的时候你笑了。所以她有这段激动人心的结束语：“我知道我拥有一个虚弱女人的身体，但我拥有国王的心和胃，而且是英格兰国王的心和胃。如果帕尔马、西班牙或欧洲任何君主胆敢入侵我的领土，我将视其为奇耻大辱。”所以她是在
those words in August 1588 as she rallies troops who've gathered at Tilbury in Essex in readiness for a landing on English soil of a Spanish army led by the Duke of Palmer, who is the most feared general in Europe. But of course, Dominic, that landing never happens. It doesn't happen. But, I mean, that's like saying Bonaparte's invasion never happened, and that doesn't diminish Nelson's greatness. No, because the Spanish Armada is defeated, first of all, by Protestant ships and then by Protestant wind. Right, and by Protestant rhetoric before that, thanks to Elizabeth, surely. Absolutely. And I guess that moment, so just as, if you take the example of Nelson or the example of Churchill, both of those become legendary immediately.
1588 年 8 月说出这些话的，当时她正在埃塞克斯郡的蒂尔伯里集结军队，准备应对由欧洲最令人畏惧的将军帕尔马公爵率领的西班牙军队在英格兰土地上的登陆。但当然，多米尼克，那次登陆从未发生。确实没发生。但是，这就像说波拿巴的入侵从未发生过一样，但这并不会削弱纳尔逊的伟大。不，因为西班牙无敌舰队首先是被新教徒的船只击败的，然后是被“新教徒之风”击败的。没错，而且在此之前，多亏了伊丽莎白，还有新教徒的修辞。绝对是这样。我想那一刻，就像你以纳尔逊或丘吉尔为例一样，他们两人都立即成为了传奇。
They've become folk stories that become foundational moments in, in. Britain's national identity. That's true of Elizabeth at Tilbury and England's national identity, isn't it? Right away, it is embedded in the national imagination. Yeah, well, it's, I mean, it's Aaron Spencer, who's writing the fairy queen in the 1890s, so, you know, less than a decade after that speech. And he portrays Elizabeth in all kinds of different ways. So there's Gloria Arna, but there is also this kind of Amazonian figure called Britomart, who is a, she's a kind of peerless female knight, much better than most of the male night. But there is also. And then, um, most of the male knights in the poem. And all who see her are all struck by her. So to quote Spencer,
他们变成了民间故事，成为了英国民族认同的基础时刻。伊丽莎白在蒂尔伯里的那一刻以及英国的民族认同也是如此，不是吗？它立刻就植根于民族想象之中了。是的，我的意思是，是埃德蒙·斯宾塞在 1590 年代写了《仙后》，所以，你知道，在那次演讲之后不到十年。他以各种不同的方式描绘了伊丽莎白。所以有“格洛丽安娜”，但也有一个叫布里托玛特（Britomart）的亚马逊式人物，她是一位无与伦比的女骑士，比诗中大多数男骑士都要出色。而且所有见到她的人都被她所震撼。引用斯宾塞的话说，
it seemed that Bologna in that warlike wise to them appeared with shield and armor fit. And this sense of Elizabeth as a warrior queen, you get it in paintings, in dramas, in novels and films. So most recently, I guess, 2007, Kate Blanchett going the full gladriel in Elizabeth the Golden Age. So I think, that four and a half centuries on, she remains definitely, I think, the most generally admired of England's rulers. But I think also, she's kind of loved in a way that most English kings and queens tend not to be. So if you think of Judy Dench winning an Oscar in Shakespeare in love, I mean, she's literally on the screen for about three minutes. And that Oscar, I think,
“似乎贝罗娜（战争女神）以那种好战的方式出现在他们面前，身披合身的盾牌和盔甲。”这种将伊丽莎白视为战士女王的感觉，你在绘画、戏剧、小说和电影中都能感受到。所以最近一次，我想是 2007 年，凯特·布兰切特在《伊丽莎白：黄金时代》中展现了完整的盖拉德丽尔风采。所以我认为，四个半世纪过去了，她绝对仍然是英国统治者中最受普遍钦佩的一位。但我认为，她也以一种大多数英国国王和女王通常不会被爱戴的方式被爱戴着。所以如果你想到朱迪·丹奇在《莎翁情史》中获得奥斯卡奖，我的意思是，她在银幕上实际上只出现了大约三分钟。而我认为那个奥斯卡奖，
in part was for Elizabeth as well as for Judy Dench. And the idea is of her as a virgin queen who's married to her people, keeping England's enemies at bay, guarding them from civil war, good Queen Bess, all of that. Do you think I think she's kind of loved as well as it might? I totally do. And putting my cards on the table, I think she is easily one of the most adept and most effective of England's rulers.
部分是给伊丽莎白的，也是给朱迪·丹奇的。人们心目中她是嫁给子民的童贞女王，将英格兰的敌人拒之门外，保护他们免受内战之苦，好女王贝丝，所有这些。你认为她是被爱戴的吗？我完全同意。摊牌来说，我认为她绝对是英国最精明、最有效的统治者之一。
And we did a series about Mary Queen of Scots. you know, another woman ruling at a similar time who makes a series of very bad choices. Elizabeth makes a series of very good ones. She's very good at politics. That said, there is a counter argument which some historians, you know, in the late 20th century, began to develop that actually she's indecisive, she's vindictive. You know, this is the sort of portraits of Elizabeth that you get with the kind of, you know, she hasn't got any teeth.
我们做过一个关于苏格兰女王玛丽的系列节目，你知道，另一位在相似时期统治的女性，她做出了一系列非常糟糕的选择。而伊丽莎白做出了一系列非常好的选择。她非常擅长政治。话虽如此，20 世纪末的一些历史学家开始提出一种反驳观点，认为实际上她优柔寡断、心胸狭隘。你知道，这就是你所得到的关于伊丽莎白的画像，比如，你知道，她没有牙齿。
Yeah, she's smelly. Yeah, all of this kind of stuff, which is very much. much the late Elizabeth. But I suppose, you know, there is this tension between the two visions of Elizabeth I first. On the one hand, she's brilliant. She's Gloria Arna. And then the other actually knows she has feet of clay. And she creates problems that end up, you know, escalating to the civil wars of the 17th century. That's the counter argument. I mean, I think that in whether you're, you're lauding her or damming her, I mean, I think there is no doubt that the best way to understand what makes her tick, what her kind of approach to politics and religion, to marriage,
是的，她身上有味道。是的，所有这些东西，这很大程度上是晚年的伊丽莎白。但我认为，在关于伊丽莎白一世的两种愿景之间确实存在这种张力。一方面，她是辉煌的，她是“格洛丽安娜”。而另一方面，实际上她也有致命弱点。她制造的问题最终升级为 17 世纪的内战。这就是反驳观点。我的意思是，我认为无论你是赞美她还是谴责她，毫无疑问，了解她行为动机的最佳方式，了解她对政治、宗教、婚姻的态度，
to parliament, to all these kind of strands within the tudor polity, the best way to understand what makes her distinctive is actually to look at her upbringing. Because one of the most extraordinary things about Elizabeth is that she ever gets to sit on the throne in the first place. So she becomes queen on the 17th November 1558, and she is 25 years. years old, but for most of those 25 years, the prospect of her ascending the throne would have seemed an incredibly remote one, because her infancy, her childhood, her adolescence, her early adulthood, kind of have the quality of a hideous fairy tale. So she's three when mummy has her head chopped off by daddy. Yeah. So that's not a good start. I mean, imagine
对议会，对都铎王朝政治中的所有这些层面，了解她独特之处的最佳方式，实际上是看她的成长经历。因为伊丽莎白最非凡的事情之一就是她竟然能坐上王位。所以她在 1558 年 11 月 17 日成为女王，当时她 25 岁，但在那 25 年的大部分时间里，她登上王位的可能性看起来都极其渺茫，因为她的婴儿期、童年、青春期、成年早期，都有着一种可怕童话的特质。所以她三岁时，妈妈就被爸爸砍了头。是的。所以这可不是个好的开始。我的意思是，想象一下
Growing up and finding out that that's what's happened. She then ends up with a stepfather who sexually abuses her. And she is then menaced by a half-sister who locks her up in the Tower of London. And Kili wants to chop her head off as her mother's head had been chopped off. But I think these traumas, these kind of the danger that she was kind of repeatedly in through her childhood and so on. I think it matters because, you know, the girl is mother to the woman. And they massively influence the kind of monarch that Elizabeth becomes, and they matter because, you know, Elizabeth ends up setting England on a course that will be massively decisive in the growth of England and of Britain and in the long run of the colonies that Britain establishes across the world. And of course, Roanoke, the first English foothold in the new world, even though it doesn't last. But it is set up in Elizabeth's reign. And Virginia, is named after Elizabeth. She's the Virgin Queen.
长大后发现发生了这种事。她后来遇到了一个性虐待她的继父。然后她又被同父异母的姐姐威胁，被关进了伦敦塔。玛丽甚至想砍掉她的头，就像她母亲的头被砍掉一样。但我认为这些创伤，她在童年时期反复经历的危险等等，我认为这很重要，因为“女孩是女人的母亲”。它们极大地影响了伊丽莎白成为什么样的君主，而且它们很重要，因为伊丽莎白最终让英格兰走上了一条对英格兰和英国的成长，以及从长远来看对英国在世界各地建立的殖民地都具有决定性意义的道路。当然，罗阿诺克，英国在新世界的第一个立足点，尽管它没能持续下去。但它是在伊丽莎白的统治下建立的。而弗吉尼亚州，就是以伊丽莎白命名的。她是童贞女王。
Well, you know what? You mentioned Brittermart. We've stayed in the Hotel Brittermart in New Zealand when we were on tour. So Elizabeth's imprint is still, you know, is there on the other side of the world. Yeah. So I think that tracing the young Elizabeth, before she becomes Elizabeth I think it's well worth doing. And we'll set up some episodes that we'll be doing in due course on the Tudor Cold War, the Spanish Armada, maybe Shakespeare. We've got lots to come on that. So as we say, it is amazing that she ends up becoming queen, but it is true that she is born a princess, the daughter of a king, and not just that, when she's delivered on the 7th of September 1533, between three and four of the clock afternoon, she does rank as the immediate heir to the throne. So at the beginning, she does seem destined to become queen. Everything that could properly have been done to prepare her for her arrival had been done. So on the 26th of August, 1533. Her mother, she was in the Palace of Greenwich downriver from London. She's gone to a very
好吧，你知道吗？你提到了布里托玛特。我们在巡回演出时曾住在新西兰的布里托玛特酒店。所以伊丽莎白的印记仍然存在于世界的另一端。是的。所以我认为追踪年轻的伊丽莎白，在她成为伊丽莎白一世之前，是非常值得做的。我们将为未来适时制作的一些剧集做铺垫，比如都铎冷战、西班牙无敌舰队，也许还有莎士比亚。我们有很多内容要讲。所以正如我们所说，她最终成为女王是令人惊奇的，但确实她生来就是公主，是国王的女儿，不仅如此，当她在 1533 年 9 月 7 日下午三点到四点之间出生时，她确实被列为王位的直接继承人。所以起初，她似乎注定要成为女王。所有本该为她的到来所做的准备工作都已完成。所以 1533 年 8 月 26 日，她的母亲在伦敦下游的格林威治宫。她去了一个非常
luxuriously appointed chamber. So David Starkey and his great book on the young Elizabeth Elizabeth apprenticeship describes it as a cross between a chapel and a luxuriously padded cell. So there are carpets everywhere. There are tapestries on the walls. There's an absolutely massive bed that amazing. I kind of read up on it. It belonged to the younger brother of the Duke of Alignor, who was captured at Agincourt. You remember? Yeah. So he was a hostage, right?
豪华的房间。所以大卫·斯塔基在他关于年轻伊丽莎白学徒生涯的伟大著作中将其描述为教堂和豪华软包牢房的结合体。所以到处都是地毯。墙上挂着挂毯。有一张绝对巨大的床，太神奇了。我读过相关资料。它属于在阿金库尔战役中被俘的奥尔良公爵的弟弟，你还记得吗？是的。所以他是一个人质，对吧？
Yeah, forever. And he kind of ends up writing poetry in English as well as French. But it was his younger brother, and this, the younger brother, Duke, Leonia, had been a hostage in England since 1412 himself. So he'd obviously left this massive bed, which was nice of him. No men are allowed into this chamber. All the companions, the attendants, the midwives, they're all women. And so beyond the, this very female space.
是的，永远都是。他最终用英语和法语写诗。但那是他的弟弟，这位弟弟，奥尔良公爵，自 1412 年以来一直是他自己在英国的人质。所以他显然留下了这张巨大的床，这对他来说很不错。不允许任何男人进入这个房间。所有的同伴、侍从、助产士，全都是女性。所以在这个非常女性化的空间之外，
All the men are waiting the king, the court, England, Europe. They're all on tenterhooks. And letters have been written, ready to reclaim the birth of what is hoped is going to be a prince to the other courts of Europe. The king of France has been squared as a godfather. A massive tournament is scheduled to be held in celebration. But in the event, of course, they're all cancelled. There is no national rejoicing. I mean, it's true. The baby is healthy. The mother hasn't died in childbirth, but these pluses do not make up for the fact that it's a crushing disappointment that the newborn baby, the heir to the throne of England, is not a boy. It's a girl.
所有的男人都在等待——国王、宫廷、英格兰、欧洲。他们都如坐针毡。信件已经写好，准备向欧洲其他宫廷宣布一个被寄予厚望的王子的诞生。法国国王已经被安排担任教父。一场盛大的锦标赛计划举行以示庆祝。但最终，当然，它们都被取消了。没有全国性的欢庆。我的意思是，确实，婴儿很健康，母亲没有死于难产，但这些优点并不能弥补一个令人心碎的失望，那就是刚出生的婴儿，英格兰王位的继承人，不是个男孩。是个女孩。
And what is worse, the mother has promised, you know, her husband that it will be a boy. And the baby being a boy has been central to the relationship between the mother. mother and father and indeed to England's history, as we'll see, because of course, you haven't named the parents yet, Tom. I know you've done that deliberately as an exciting reveal for the audience. So to explain why it matters so much that the child is a boy, that Elizabeth, and in fact Elizabeth isn't a boy, we need to go back to the parents, don't we? So let's kick off with the father. Who's the father? Well, the father, Dominic, it will amazing you to learn, is Henry the 8th. and I guess he's the only English monarch who can rival his daughter for kind of instant recognizability, wouldn't you say?
更糟糕的是，母亲曾向她的丈夫承诺会是个男孩。而婴儿是男孩一直是母亲和父亲之间关系的核心，实际上也是英格兰历史的核心，正如我们将要看到的，因为当然，你还没提到父母的名字，汤姆。我知道你是故意这样做的，作为给观众的一个激动人心的揭秘。所以为了解释为什么孩子是男孩如此重要，为什么伊丽莎白，事实上伊丽莎白不是个男孩，我们需要回到她的父母，不是吗？所以让我们从父亲开始。父亲是谁？好吧，父亲，多米尼克，你会惊讶地发现，是亨利八世。而且我想他是唯一能与他的女儿在即时辨识度上相媲美的英国君主，你觉得呢？
I would say not only instantly recognisable, I would say the single most important ruler. I mean, not necessarily the best. I think Elizabeth has a good claim to be the best, but he's the one that matters. The most consequential, isn't he? Yeah, the most consequential ruler in England's history, and indeed in Britain's history, I would say. So when Elizabeth is born, he is 42, and he's a man of very imposing charisma and accomplishment. So he's been on the throne for 24 years since a very young man. When he came to
我会说不仅是即时可辨认，我会说他是最重要的一位统治者。我的意思是，不一定是最好的。我认为伊丽莎白有很好的理由成为最好的，但他才是那个关键人物。他是最有影响力的，不是吗？是的，他是英格兰历史上，实际上也是英国历史上最有影响力的统治者。所以当伊丽莎白出生时，他 42 岁，是一个拥有非常令人印象深刻的魅力和成就的男人。所以他已经在位 24 年了，从很年轻的时候开始。当他来到
the throne, he was renowned as a kind of an elite sportsman. People went into rhapsodies over his athletic achievements. By now he is starting to run to fat. He hasn't gone the full obesity. But he's still a very imposing figure. He's poised between Damien Lewis and Charles Lawton, isn't he? He's not quite one or the other. So he's got red hair. He's very athletic. He's described as having an extremely fine calf to his leg, which obviously matters in the Tudor court, where a fine calf is very important. And the presence of Venetian ambassadors at the Tudor court is tremendous for historians, because they give very kind of detailed accounts. So one of the Vian ambassadors described to Henry is gifted with mental accomplishments as he is most excellent in
王位时，他以精英运动员而闻名。人们对他的运动成就赞不绝口。到目前为止，他开始发胖了。他还没有完全肥胖。但他仍然是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物。他介于达米安·刘易斯和查尔斯·劳顿之间，不是吗？他不是完全像其中任何一个。所以他有红头发。他非常健壮。他被描述为有一双非常漂亮的小腿，这在都铎宫廷中显然很重要，因为漂亮的小腿非常重要。威尼斯大使在都铎宫廷的存在对历史学家来说是巨大的财富，因为他们提供了非常详细的记录。所以其中一位威尼斯大使描述亨利拥有与他卓越的
his personal endowments. So he's fluent in Latin, in French, in Spanish. He has a very good Italian, in. He's kind of got rudimentary Greek. He's very musical. Sadly, he didn't compose green sleeves. But he is a composer. He plays the harp, very good on the keyboards. So that's very impressive. And he also fancies himself as a theologian. So he had written a takedown of Martin Luther. And the Pope had named him Defender of the Faith for this in 1521. And this is a title of which he's inordinately proud, and which the British monarch still has to this day. Yeah, it's the same the Pope. The Pope's let themselves down after that, didn't they?
个人天赋一样出色的智力成就。所以他精通拉丁语、法语、西班牙语。他的意大利语非常好。他还有基本的希腊语。他非常有音乐天赋。遗憾的是，他没有创作《绿袖子》。但他是一位作曲家。他弹竖琴，键盘乐器也弹得很好。所以这非常令人印象深刻。而且他还自认为是神学家。所以他写过一篇抨击马丁·路德的文章。教皇在 1521 年为此授予他“信仰捍卫者”的称号。这是一个他引以为傲的头衔，英国君主至今仍保留着。是的，教皇。教皇在那之后让自己失望了，不是吗？
But we've kept the title, which is important. This is, yeah. So, yeah, there's lots to come on that score. So he's often seen, isn't he, as part of a trio of slightly larger-than-life monarchs who dominate Europe. But of the three of them, he is the junior, isn't he? The other two are Francis or Francois, the first of France. who's this sort of incredibly priapic.
但我们保留了这个头衔，这很重要。这是，是的。所以，关于这一点还有很多要讲的。所以他经常被视为统治欧洲的几位略显夸张的君主之一，不是吗？但在他们三人中，他是最年轻的，不是吗？另外两位是法国的弗朗索瓦一世。他是一个极其好色的人。
He's a roister in his own way, isn't he? And then Charles V, the Habsburg Emperor, who is absolutely not a roisterer. He is a very melancholy brooding man, but he's probably the top dog and then the French king. Oh, undoubtedly, I think, because I mean, he's the emperor. So he's got Germany, he's got the low countries, he's got much of Italy, but he's also the king of Spain. Yeah. And of course, Spain means that he's also the ruler of vast chunks of the new world. Yeah.
他以自己的方式是一个狂欢者，不是吗？然后是哈布斯堡王朝的皇帝查理五世，他绝对不是一个狂欢者。他是一个非常忧郁、沉思的人，但他可能是老大，然后是法国国王。哦，毫无疑问，我认为，因为我的意思是，他是皇帝。所以他拥有德国、低地国家、意大利的大部分地区，但他也是西班牙国王。是的。当然，西班牙意味着他也是新世界广阔领土的统治者。是的。
So he's got all the silver coming. in from the new world. So he is overwhelmingly the most powerful ruler in Europe, I think. Then Francois and then Henry. But the thing about Henry is he's very, very good at punching above his weight. You know, he projects this kind of vibrant image. Yeah. And his weight is quite something. So that's pretty good. And this makes him popular with the English. They feel they're not embarrassed to have him as a king. They feel he, you know, he's giving them a good image, I think, is what they feel. I think that's the one thing that people always get wrong about him to the eighth. When they say, oh, he's a monster, he's this, is that. At the time, people in England, they might
所以他有所有从新世界运来的白银。所以我认为他绝对是欧洲最强大的统治者。然后是弗朗索瓦，然后是亨利。但亨利的问题在于他非常、非常擅长以弱胜强。你知道，他投射出这种充满活力的形象。是的。而且他的体重相当可观。所以这相当不错。这使他在英国人中很受欢迎。他们觉得有他作为国王并不丢脸。他们觉得他，你知道，给了他们一个很好的形象，我想这就是他们的感受。我认为这是人们在亨利八世身上总是搞错的一件事。当他们说，哦，他是个怪物，他是这个，是那个。当时，英格兰的人们，他们可能
have been frightened of him, or they might have thought he was making strange and unpopular decisions. But nobody ever doubted that he was good at being a king, and that he was good at standing up for England, and that he, you know, embodied English independence and defiance and all those kinds of things. I mean, he's very good at it. He is. He's a massive, great slab of beef on the English throne, and that's what the English like to see. Like, if he and both Botham was King of England. Well, I think Ian Botham is well Charles Brandon, his mate. He is.
会害怕他，或者他们可能认为他正在做出奇怪且不受欢迎的决定。但没有人怀疑他擅长做国王，他擅长为英格兰挺身而出，他，你知道，体现了英格兰的独立、反抗和所有这些东西。我的意思是，他非常擅长。他是。他是英格兰王位上一块巨大的牛肉，而这正是英国人喜欢看到的。就像如果他和伊恩·博瑟姆是英格兰国王。好吧，我认为伊恩·博瑟姆是查尔斯·布兰登，他的伙伴。他是。
Yeah, he completely is. He's an absolute ledge, Henry V. 8. But there's an issue, isn't this? So he may well be a bit of a legend. And yet at the same time, he's a worrier. He's insecure and he's insecure for good reasons. And this is the other thing that I think is, I mean, I think this is absolutely central to understand the whole story of the Tudors, why he has six wives, why he breaks with Rome,
是的，他完全是。他绝对是个传奇，亨利八世。但有一个问题，不是吗？所以他可能确实是个传奇。但与此同时，他是一个忧虑者。他缺乏安全感，而且他有充分的理由缺乏安全感。我认为这是绝对核心的，去理解整个都铎王朝的故事，为什么他有六个妻子，为什么他与罗马决裂，
all of this stuff. The fact is the Tudors should not be there. They are usurpers. And we know the wars of the roses are over, the civil wars, but they don't. As far as they're concerned, they could still be in the wars of the roses because there are a lot of other people who think they shouldn't be here. They're just parvenues, their Nouveau-Riche. What are they even doing on the throne?
所有这些事情。事实是都铎王朝本不应该在那里。他们是篡位者。我们知道玫瑰战争结束了，内战结束了，但他们并不这么认为。就他们而言，他们可能仍然处于玫瑰战争中，因为还有很多人认为他们不应该在这里。他们只是暴发户，新贵。他们凭什么坐在王位上？
Yeah. And so that makes it absolutely essential that every Tudor king has a male heir because otherwise the throne comes up for grabs again and civil war may break out. Yeah. So Henry's father, Henry the 7th, had defeated Richard the 3rd at the Battle of Bosworth. His reign had been, you know, there'd been all kinds of attempted coups, rebellions. Henry had put them down, and also he had done his duty by fathering sons. So his first son, Arthur, dies at the age of 15, but it's okay because he has a spare.
是的。所以这使得每一位都铎王朝的国王拥有男性继承人变得绝对必要，否则王位就会再次被争夺，内战可能会爆发。是的。所以亨利的父亲，亨利七世，在博斯沃思战役中击败了理查三世。他的统治，你知道，经历过各种政变企图、叛乱。亨利平定了它们，而且他也通过生儿子尽到了自己的职责。所以他的第一个儿子亚瑟在 15 岁时去世了，但没关系，因为他有一个备胎。
And that spare, of course, is the Henry who will go on to become Henry the 8th. And Henry not only inherits Arthur's title as Prince of Wales, but he also inherits Arthur's wife, Catherine of Aragon. And Catherine is the daughter of Ferdinand and Isabella, who are probably the most formidable Christian monarchs of their generation. I mean, that's a massive tribute to Henry the 7th's diplomacy. I mean, Henry the 7th, by the way, I think is a brilliant king. And he has managed to get a deal for his sons that they will marry this princess. And he's punching above his weight there. I think there's no doubt. Because Ferdinand and Isabella, their reputation is well known across Europe.
而那个备胎，当然就是后来成为亨利八世的亨利。亨利不仅继承了亚瑟威尔士亲王的头衔，他还继承了亚瑟的妻子，阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。凯瑟琳是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的女儿，他们可能是他们那一代最令人生畏的基督教君主。我的意思是，这对亨利七世的外交是一个巨大的赞誉。我的意思是，顺便说一句，我认为亨利七世是一位出色的国王。他成功地为他的儿子们达成了一项协议，他们将娶这位公主。他在那里以弱胜强。我认为毫无疑问。因为斐迪南和伊莎贝拉，他们的名声在欧洲广为人知。
They're the people who sent Columbus. They're the people who have made Spain a united country. They are presiding over a country that is rising to become a genuine world power, with all these holdings in the new world and stuff. Yeah, I mean, in a way, the first genuine world power in history. So this is a brilliant deal that Henry the 7th has got for, I mean, this is the mad thing about ditching Catherine of Aragon. You know, you've got such a great deal in marrying Catherine of Aragon. Yeah. And also Catherine of Aragon is the aunt of the Emperor Charles
他们是派遣哥伦布的人。他们是使西班牙成为统一国家的人。他们统治着一个正在崛起成为真正世界强国的国家，拥有所有这些在新世界的领地等等。是的，在某种程度上，这是历史上第一个真正的世界强国。所以这是亨利七世达成的一项绝妙的交易，我的意思是，这就是抛弃阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的疯狂之处。你知道，你娶阿拉贡的凯瑟琳得到了这么好的交易。是的。而且阿拉贡的凯瑟琳也是皇帝查理五世的姨妈，
the 5th who rules Spain as Charles I, because Charles V is the grandson of Ferdinand and Isabella. And that kind of relationship between Catherine of Aragon and Charles V is going to play an important part in this story. And just on this, so Henry and Catherine of Aragon get on really well at first, don't they? They're actually quite a happy couple and everybody says, oh, things are great. But there is this one big issue, which is where is the air? You know, everything is fine apart from that, actually. They do get on pretty well by and large. Yeah, and Catherine's very competent. So basically, it's Catherine who wins the Battle of Flodden against the Scots, the great English victory. She's a very competent ruler when Henry's off, you know, doing his wars in France. She's much loved by the English people. No, she's a great hit. but she's got to give him a son and Henry does take for granted you know people may be wondering well what's the deal with the son why not a daughter there's a very precise reason why Henry doesn't want a daughter and he he spells it out he says that if he has a daughter and then if she should chance to rule she cannot continue long without a husband which by God's law must then
他作为查理一世统治西班牙，因为查理五世是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的孙子。阿拉贡的凯瑟琳和查理五世之间的那种关系将在故事中发挥重要作用。关于这一点，亨利和阿拉贡的凯瑟琳起初相处得很好，不是吗？他们实际上是一对相当幸福的夫妇，每个人都说，哦，事情很棒。但有一个大问题，那就是继承人在哪里？你知道，除了那个，一切都很好，实际上。他们大体上相处得相当不错。是的，凯瑟琳非常有能力。所以基本上，是凯瑟琳赢得了对苏格兰的弗洛登战役，那是伟大的英格兰胜利。当亨利去法国打仗时，她是一位非常有能力的统治者。她深受英国人民的爱戴。不，她非常受欢迎。但她必须给他生个儿子，而亨利确实认为这是理所当然的，你知道，人们可能想知道，好吧，生儿子有什么大不了的，为什么不是女儿？亨利不想生女儿有一个非常精确的原因，他明确表示，他说如果他有一个女儿，然后如果她有机会统治，她不可能在没有丈夫的情况下长久维持，而根据上帝的法律，丈夫必须
be her governor and head and so finally she'll direct the realm and this is going to be an issue for Elizabeth the first I mean it's not just Henry being a chauvinist thinking that I mean it's it's an issue for Elizabeth as well. People who've listened to our series on Mary Queen of Scots who did marry very imprudently, we'll see the force of this anxiety. So it really matters that Catherine gives Henry a son. And over the course of the first decade of his reign, Catherine does repeatedly get pregnant. But tragically for her, tragically for Henry, all her babies, with one exception, are either still born or die shortly after birth. And the exception that proves the rule is a girl. And this is Princess Mary, who is born on the 18th of February 1516.
是她的统治者和首领，所以最终她将指导这个王国，这对伊丽莎白一世来说将是一个问题。我的意思是，这不仅仅是亨利作为一个沙文主义者那样想，我的意思是，这对伊丽莎白来说也是一个问题。听过我们关于苏格兰女王玛丽系列节目的人，她确实嫁得非常轻率，会看到这种焦虑的力量。所以凯瑟琳给亨利生个儿子真的很重要。在亨利统治的第一个十年里，凯瑟琳确实反复怀孕。但对她来说，对亨利来说，悲剧的是，她所有的孩子，除一个例外，要么是死胎，要么在出生后不久就夭折了。而证明规则的例外是一个女孩。这就是玛丽公主，她出生于 1516 年 2 月 18 日。
But there's still no son. And already, by 1519, foreign observers are kind of sounding the death knell for any prospect of Catherine, basically giving Henry any more children, let alone a son. So the problem is very gallantly summed up by Frossoir premier, Francis I first. He says his wife is old and deformed while he himself is young and handsome. I mean, that is harsh because basically she's not old. She's what is the late 30s or something. And she's definitely not deformed. I mean, she's quite a, you know, everybody said she's a, you know, Catherine of Aragon
但仍然没有儿子。而且到 1519 年，外国观察家们已经为凯瑟琳基本上给亨利再生孩子，更不用说儿子，敲响了丧钟。所以这个问题被弗朗索瓦一世非常豪迈地总结了。他说他的妻子又老又畸形，而他自己又年轻又英俊。我的意思是，这很刻薄，因为基本上她并不老。她大概 30 多岁还是什么的。而且她绝对不畸形。我的意思是，她是一个，你知道，每个人都说她是一个，你知道，阿拉贡的凯瑟琳
was a perfectly, you know, attractive woman. Although she is a bit older than Henry. And as time goes on, there's a definite sense, isn't there? he has, well, he's a bit bored of her, but in a way that is actually standard for monarchs, late medieval, early modern monarchs. I mean, he's sleeping around, isn't he? But this is not a sign that he's a monster. This is fairly established practice. Well, the other thing is that Henry has a sum by one of his paramours. And so this reassures him that the problem isn't with him. And by 1525, Catherine's 40. I mean, effectively by
是一个非常完美的、有吸引力的女人。尽管她比亨利大一点。随着时间的推移，有一种明确的感觉，不是吗？他，好吧，他有点厌倦她了，但以一种实际上对君主、中世纪晚期、近代早期君主来说是标准的方式。我的意思是，他在外面乱搞，不是吗？但这并不是他是个怪物的标志。这是相当确立的做法。好吧，另一件事是亨利有一个情妇生的儿子。所以这让他确信问题不在他身上。到 1525 年，凯瑟琳 40 岁了。我的意思是，实际上到
now she is, you know, by the standards of the age, past childbearing age. And so this is a huge, huge problem for Henry. And it is then in 1525 that he meets the woman who is going to upend everything, because this is a woman who is not content with being his bit on the side, with being his concubine. She wants to become his queen. And this, of course, is a very, very famous name in English history. It's Anne Boleyn. Yes. So Anne Boleyn, she's the daughter of a diplomat called Sir Thomas Boulin and she's spent a lot of time in Paris, hasn't she? Which will come to. Her French fashion is a very important part of her repertoire. But she's not, you know, she's conventionally when she's played on screen, she's very pretty. But the odd thing is she's actually not
现在，按照那个时代的标准，她已经过了生育年龄。所以这对亨利来说是一个巨大、巨大的问题。正是在 1525 年，他遇到了那个将颠覆一切的女人，因为这个女人不满足于做他的侧室，做他的情妇。她想成为他的王后。而这，当然，是英国历史上一个非常、非常著名的名字。是安妮·博林。是的。所以安妮·博林，她是外交官托马斯·博林爵士的女儿，她在巴黎待了很长时间，不是吗？这稍后会提到。她的法国时尚是她曲目中非常重要的一部分。但她不是，你知道，她在银幕上被扮演时通常是非常漂亮的。但奇怪的是，她实际上并不
terribly pretty. People actually went out of their way to comment on it, to say it's amazing that Henry has fallen for this person who actually is not especially, you know, sexy and sensation. Yeah. So we can, I mean, to look in the, what the Venetian ambassadors have to say again. So one of them, he's writing in 1532, describes Anne as of middling stature, swarthy complexion, long neck, wide mouth, bosom, not much raised. And in fact, has nothing but the English king's great appetite and her eyes, which are black
特别漂亮。人们实际上特意评论过这一点，说亨利竟然爱上了这个实际上并不特别，你知道，性感和迷人的人，这真是令人惊讶。是的。所以我们可以，我的意思是，再看看威尼斯大使们怎么说。所以其中一位，他在 1532 年写道，描述安妮为中等身材，肤色黝黑，长脖子，大嘴，胸部不太丰满。事实上，除了英国国王的巨大胃口和她的眼睛，她什么都没有，她的眼睛是黑色的
and beautiful. The other thing that kind of causes eyebrows to be raised, is, as you said, that she is not, you know, she's not of royal blood. She's not even really of aristocratic blood. You know, as you said, she's the daughter of a country squire, Sir Thomas Berlin. And he's a kind of mucker with Henry VIII. He kind of hangs out with the lads. He's a bit older than them, though.
而且很美。另一件引起人们侧目的事情是，正如你所说，她不是，你知道，她没有皇室血统。她甚至没有真正的贵族血统。你知道，正如你所说，她是乡绅托马斯·博林爵士的女儿。他是一个和亨利八世混在一起的人。他有点像和那帮小伙子混在一起。不过他比他们大一点。
But, I mean, he gets on well with Henry because he's all about, you know, horses and hunting and sport. He'd wear a jile. He'd absolutely from that kind of class. He drives a land rover. He absolutely does. Yeah, he does. He's like Fergie's father, major Ferguson. That's kind of Ronald Ferguson. But he's not really the stuff of a royal father-in-law. I mean, it seems a kind of mad idea. I mean, and it's not conventionally beautiful. She's not of, you know, the kind of pedigree that would mark her out as a potential royal wife. And so the question is then, you know,
但是，我的意思是，他与亨利相处得很好，因为他热衷于，你知道，马匹、狩猎和运动。他会穿吉列背心。他绝对是那种阶层的人。他开路虎。他绝对是。他就像弗吉的父亲，弗格森少校。那是罗纳德·弗格森。但他真的不是皇室岳父的料。我的意思是，这似乎是一个疯狂的想法。我的意思是，她并不传统地美丽。她没有，你知道，那种能让她成为潜在皇室妻子的血统。所以问题就在于，你知道，
what's she bringing to the party? How does she get Henry to think of her as a, a, a, a possible queen. And you mentioned her, her kind of French glamour. She has been at the French court a fair while. She's very smart. She's very sophisticated. She's very stylish. And in an age when French fashion kind of is the marker for people in England, she has, so Tracy Borman, she wrote a brilliant book on Amber Lynn and her relationship to Elizabeth. She describes it as an irresistible jeune-se-cois. So she sings, she dances, she plays musical instruments much better than any of the ladies at the English court. She's sensationally well-dressed. And while she loves fashion for its own sake, she also knows that fashion matters for someone
她给这场派对带来了什么？她是如何让亨利认为她是一个，一个，一个，可能的王后的。你提到了她，她那种法国魅力。她在法国宫廷待了相当长一段时间。她非常聪明。她非常世俗。她非常时髦。而且在一个法国时尚在英格兰被视为人们标志的时代，她拥有，所以特蕾西·博曼，她写了一本关于安妮·博林和她与伊丽莎白关系的精彩著作。她将其描述为一种不可抗拒的“我不知道是什么”（je ne sais quoi）。所以她唱歌、跳舞、演奏乐器比英国宫廷里的任何女士都要好。她穿得非常漂亮。虽然她为了时尚本身而热爱时尚，但她也知道时尚对于一个
who wants to be a queen. If you want to be a queen, you have to look like a queen. She's very good at that. She's also, she's very clever. And she, again, I think is intellectual. in a way. Henry's very smart. I think there's a meeting of minds there. And Anne, while she was at the French court, was strongly influenced by a very remarkable woman, Marguerite of Navarre, who's the sister of Francis I. And she is very interested in Luther. She's very interested in all the kind of the trendiest, most cutting edge currents of religious thought that are coming out of Germany at the time. The Reformation is kind of kicking off. She has, I mean, she's not a Protestant, which in any way would would be an anachronistic word at this point. Protestants as such don't exist yet.
想要成为王后的人来说很重要。如果你想成为王后，你必须看起来像个王后。她非常擅长这一点。她也非常聪明。而且她，我再次认为，在某种程度上是知识分子。亨利非常聪明。我认为他们在思想上有共鸣。而安妮，当她在法国宫廷时，深受一位非常了不起的女性的影响，玛格丽特·德·纳瓦拉，她是弗朗索瓦一世的妹妹。她对路德非常感兴趣。她对当时从德国传出的所有那种最时髦、最前沿的宗教思想潮流非常感兴趣。宗教改革正在开始。她有，我的意思是，她不是新教徒，在这个时候用这个词会是时代错误。新教徒作为这样一个群体还不存在。
She's a reformer. She's an evangelical. And she admires Luther. And Anne seems to have picked up various evangelical ideas from her. So these would include the idea that you could have a direct unmediated relationship with God, that you don't need priests to kind of mediate between you and the divine. The urgent need for everyone, not just those who can read Latin, to have access to scripture. So the idea that the Bible should be readily available in the vernacular and a sense that the church is corrupt and that it needs to be reformed and a particular anxiety about a papacy that seems very corrupt and worldly. And Marguerite herself never goes so far as to say, well, we should cast off papal supremacy. We should bin the Pope. But I think Anne, certainly by the time she gets
她是一位改革者。她是一位福音派。她钦佩路德。安妮似乎从她那里学到了一些福音派思想。这些思想包括你可以与上帝建立直接的、无中介的关系，你不需要牧师在上帝和神圣之间进行调解；每个人，不仅仅是那些能读拉丁语的人，都需要接触圣经的迫切需要。所以圣经应该以白话文形式随时可用，以及一种教会腐败需要改革的感觉，特别是对一个看起来非常腐败和世俗的教皇制度的焦虑。玛格丽特本人从未走得那么远，说，好吧，我们应该抛弃教皇至上。我们应该扔掉教皇。但我认为安妮，肯定是在她从法国宫廷
back to England from the French court, I think she's gone the full Luther. I think she's kind of buying into that. So what all that means is she's very stylish, she's very fashionable, she's continental, she's sophisticated, she's returned to England with the latest ideas that a lot of people in England are only just struggling to get their heads around. She's clearly very poised, self-confident. I guess she offers something that Catherine, who's always been a very dutiful wife, you know, perhaps slightly unassuming, I mean by royal standards.
回到英格兰时，我认为她已经完全接受了路德的思想。我认为她正在接受这一点。所以这一切意味着她非常时髦，她非常时尚，她是大陆派，她很世俗，她带着英格兰许多人刚刚才开始努力理解的最新思想回到了英格兰。她显然非常镇定、自信。我想她提供了一些凯瑟琳，那个一直是一个非常顺从的妻子，你知道，也许稍微有点谦逊，我的意思是按照皇室标准。
You know, she offers something that Catherine doesn't and that also Henry's various kind of mistresses don't offer. She seems much cooler, doesn't she? She's spikier. She can be a bit difficult, Anne, you know, as in she's a surbic and she can be very scornful and scathing. But she's really, she's interesting. Well, and also she plays him brilliantly
你知道，她提供了一些凯瑟琳没有提供的东西，而且亨利的各种情妇也没有提供。她看起来酷多了，不是吗？她更尖锐。安妮可能会有点难相处，你知道，因为她尖刻，她可能会非常轻蔑和刻薄。但她真的，她很有趣。好吧，而且她也玩弄他玩得非常出色
because most of the ladies in the court, you know, if Henry comes calling, they're very flattered and basically kind of give in to him. Anne doesn't. She's described as tantalizing him with her pretty dugs, but that's basically as far as it goes. And she tells him very forthrightly, I would rather lose my life than my honesty. And so she tells him, you know, if you want to sleep with me, then you're going to have to make an honest woman of me. And that means making her Henry's queen.
因为宫廷里的大多数女士，你知道，如果亨利来找她们，她们会受宠若惊，基本上会屈服于他。安妮没有。她被描述为用她漂亮的乳房挑逗他，但基本上也就到此为止了。她非常直率地告诉他，我宁愿失去生命也不愿失去我的贞洁。所以她告诉他，你知道，如果你想和我睡觉，那么你必须让我成为一个正派的女人。这意味着让她成为亨利的王后。
I mean, that is, just to pause a second, that is bonkers by the standards of that. I mean, people, all through English history, there have been kings with mistresses. Well, you're absolutely right. But there is a special circumstance, which is that Henry is married to a woman who he thinks can't give him a son. He suspects that and hopes that Anne can. And more than that, Anne has a way of cutting the Gordian knot around the marriage, because there is a huge issue around any prospect of divorce. Because marriage, according to the church, is a sacrament instituted by Christ himself. So what God has joined together, let no man put a son.
我的意思是，这，暂停一下，按照那个时代的标准，这简直是疯了。我的意思是，人们，在整个英国历史上，一直有国王有情妇。好吧，你是完全正确的。但有一个特殊情况，那就是亨利娶了一个他认为不能给他生儿子的女人。他怀疑这一点，并希望安妮能做到。而且不仅如此，安妮有一种绕过婚姻周围的戈耳狄俄斯之结的方法，因为关于离婚的任何前景都有一个巨大的问题。因为婚姻，根据教会的说法，是基督亲自设立的圣礼。所以上帝所配合的，人不可分开。
I mean, that seems absolutely black and white. How do you get round that? Well, Henry has come to believe that his marriage to Catherine is invalid and an offence to God and that therefore God wants it dissolved. And in Henry's opinion, Catherine's failure to give him a son is clear evidence of divine anger. And he and his kind of tame clerics cite a verse from Leviticus in the Old Testament, if a man shall take his brother's wife, it is an ungrine. clean thing. He hath uncovered his brother's nakedness. They shall be childless. And of course, Henry has taken his brother's wife. Catherine was the widow of Arthur. Henry then married him. He'd got a special papal dispensation to do that. But he's now thinking that dispensation,
我的意思是，这看起来绝对是黑白分明的。你怎么绕过这个问题呢？嗯，亨利已经开始相信，他与凯瑟琳的婚姻是无效的，是对上帝的冒犯，因此上帝希望解除这段婚姻。在亨利看来，凯瑟琳没能为他生下一个儿子，就是上帝愤怒的明确证据。他和那些唯命是从的教士们引用了《旧约·利未记》中的一节经文：人若娶了弟兄的妻，便是污秽的事，羞辱了他的弟兄，二人必无子女。当然，亨利确实娶了他兄弟的妻子。凯瑟琳是亚瑟的遗孀。亨利随后娶了她。他为此获得了教皇的特别豁免。但他现在认为，那种豁免，
you know, doesn't cut the mustard with God. And so he's been pressing the Pope to grant him an annulment. And probably under normal circumstances, the Pope would have been happy to oblige. But the problem is, as we mentioned, Catherine, is Charles the Fifth's armed, and the Pope, given a choice, is always going to risk offending Henry rather than Charles the Fifth. Of course, because they, I mean, just to give people a sense of the context, Rome has just been sacked by Charles the Fifth's troops, right? The Pope is effectively Charles the Fifth's prisoner. He's never going to, he's never going to offend Charles the Fifth. Yeah. And so this leaves Henry and his ministers in an absolute jam. And so it's called the King's Great Matter. How do you get a divorce when the one person who can grant that divorce, the Pope, is not going to give it to you? And so it's locked Henry into years of fruitless negotiations and frustration. I mean, it's kind of incredibly Brexit. Ambassadors endlessly going and being rebuffed. But now, not only is he attracted to Anne. Not only does he think she can give him the son that he so desperately wants, but she can also provide the key that would unlock the king's great matter.
你知道，在上帝面前根本行不通。所以他一直向教皇施压，要求准予他离婚。在正常情况下，教皇可能很乐意效劳。但问题正如我们提到的，凯瑟琳是查理五世的姨妈，教皇如果面临选择，总是宁愿冒犯亨利，也不愿冒犯查理五世。当然，因为他们，我的意思是，为了让大家了解背景，罗马刚刚被查理五世的军队洗劫了，对吧？教皇实际上是查理五世的囚徒。他绝不会，绝不会冒犯查理五世。是的。这让亨利和他的大臣们陷入了绝对的困境。所以这被称为“国王的重大事务”。当唯一能批准离婚的人——教皇——不给你离婚时，你该怎么办？这让亨利陷入了多年毫无结果的谈判和挫折中。我的意思是，这简直就像英国脱欧一样不可思议。大使们不断地去，又不断地被拒绝。但现在，他不仅被安妮吸引。不仅认为她能给他梦寐以求的儿子，而且她还能提供解开“国王重大事务”的钥匙。
Because if, as Luther teaches and Anne has come to think, the Pope is the great whore of Babylon, the Antichrist, then who cares what the Pope thinks? Yeah. Doesn't matter. Yeah. So in many ways, this is a win-win for him. Henry, because not only will he get the woman he wants, if this all works out, but he will throw off foreign influence, become master in his own house, as it were, in religious terms, and also in the long run, of course, there was all that, there's all those monasteries.
因为如果像路德所教导的那样，安妮也开始认为，教皇是巴比伦的大淫妇，是敌基督，那么谁还在乎教皇怎么想呢？是的。没关系。是的。所以在很多方面，这对亨利来说是双赢的。因为如果这一切顺利，他不仅能得到他想要的女人，而且他还能摆脱外国的影响，在宗教层面上成为自己家里的主人，从长远来看，当然，还有那些修道院。
Very tempting. Yeah, there's all kinds of good Eastern prospect. And so Henry summons a load of scholars to weigh this up. their English scholars. And amazingly, they tell him, yeah, brilliant, go for it. And the guy who takes the lead in this is a very brilliant scholar called Thomas Cranmer, who will be hearing about over the course of this series. He's going to be a key player.
非常诱人。是的，各种各样的前景都很好。于是亨利召集了一群学者来权衡这件事。他们是英国学者。令人惊讶的是，他们告诉他，太棒了，去做吧。带头做这件事的人是一位非常杰出的学者，名叫托马斯·克兰麦，我们将在本系列节目中听到关于他的消息。他将是一个关键人物。
But basically, Thomas Cranmer and his fellow scholars demonstrate to Henry satisfaction that his power as king is superior to that of the popes. And once that's been accepted by Henry, things then move very far. So in 1531, the English Church grants Henry the title of singular protector, Supreme Lord, and even so far as the law of Christ allows supreme head of the English church and clergy. So that's essentially shunting the Pope to one side. In the same year, Catherine is banished from court and her apartments are given to one of her former ladies in waiting, and that is Amber Lynn.
但基本上，托马斯·克兰麦和他的同僚们向亨利证明，他作为国王的权力高于教皇。一旦亨利接受了这一点，事情就进展得非常快。因此在1531年，英国教会授予亨利“唯一保护者”、“最高领主”的头衔，甚至在基督律法允许的范围内，成为英国教会和神职人员的最高首脑。所以这本质上是把教皇推到了一边。同年，凯瑟琳被逐出宫廷，她的公寓被给了她以前的一位侍女，那就是安妮·博林。
The following year, Anne is raised to the peerage in her own right, the first woman to be honored in this way. And she's granted the Marquisate of Pembroke, which is an extinct title that Henry resurrects. And this matters because Henry can only marry someone of that rank. The people who listened to the series we did on Mary Queen of Scots this July may remember that every time Mary Queen of Scots makes one of her unfortunate marriages, she has to raise her husband to be to a dukedom so that he will be of worthy rank to be married to a queen. So basically that's what Henry is doing with Anne here. By December 1532, Anne knows she's pregnant.
第二年，安妮以她自己的权利被提升为贵族，她是第一位以这种方式获得荣誉的女性。她被授予彭布罗克侯爵爵位，这是一个亨利复兴的已废除的头衔。这很重要，因为亨利只能娶那个等级的人。今年7月听过我们关于苏格兰玛丽女王系列节目的听众可能记得，每当苏格兰玛丽女王进行一次不幸的婚姻时，她都必须将她的丈夫提升为公爵，这样他才有资格娶女王。所以基本上这就是亨利在这里对安妮所做的事情。到1532年12月，安妮知道她怀孕了。
And so, you know, things, the foot really needs to be put down on the pedal. So on the 25th of January, 1533, Henry marries her in his private chapel in Westminster, despite the fact that actually the annulment of his marriage to Catherine still hasn't come through. So effectively, he's now bigamous. On the 30th of March, Thomas Cranmer is consecrated as the Archbishop of Canterbury. and he gets the job because Henry knows that, you know, he's going to do what he needs the Archbishop to do, which is basically to absolutely affirm the legitimacy of what he's going through. So at Easter 1533, again quoting the Venetian ambassador, the Marchioness Anne went with the king
所以，你知道，事情真的需要加快步伐了。因此，1533年1月25日，亨利在威斯敏斯特的私人礼拜堂娶了她，尽管事实上他与凯瑟琳的婚姻无效化还没有完成。所以实际上，他现在犯了重婚罪。3月30日，托马斯·克兰麦被祝圣为坎特伯雷大主教。他得到这份工作是因为亨利知道，他会做他需要大主教做的事，也就是基本上绝对肯定他所经历的事情的合法性。所以1533年复活节，再次引用威尼斯大使的话，安妮侯爵夫人与国王一起
to high mass as queen and with all the pomp of a queen clad in cloth of gold and loaded with the richest jewels and she dined in public. Then on the 29th of May, she said, from the Palace of Greenwich, up the River Thames, to the Tower of London. She steps out from the boat. She goes round to the main entrance into the tower, crosses the moat. She's greeted by Henry with a kiss, and the couple retire to apartments that Henry has had decorated in splendid magnificence, specifically for Anne. Two days later, she makes her ceremonial entry into London, dressed in white, and she is
作为王后参加了弥撒，并带着王后的所有排场，身穿金布，佩戴着最昂贵的珠宝，她在公共场合用餐。然后5月29日，她从格林威治宫出发，沿着泰晤士河向上游航行，前往伦敦塔。她从船上走下来。她绕到塔楼的正门，穿过护城河。她受到亨利的亲吻迎接，这对夫妇退到了亨利专门为安妮装饰得极其华丽的公寓里。两天后，她身穿白衣，举行了进入伦敦的仪式，她被
extolled as a splendid image of chastity. And on the 1st of June 1533, she is anointed, and the crown of St. Edward the confessor is placed on her head. And this is the crown that is usually reserved for the monarch himself. So it is a signal honour. So the reason for this signal honour, presumably, is because it's very obvious to everybody now. If she knew she was pregnant in December, it must be obvious to everybody now that she is expecting a child. And the general assumption is that this will be, the assumption based on nothing is that this will be a son. Well, so it's, I mean, she's being described as a splendid image of chastity, but she's also being described as somewhat big with child. And so you're right that this pregnancy reassures Henry. Brilliant.
赞誉为贞洁的绝佳形象。1533年6月1日，她被涂油，忏悔者圣爱德华的王冠被戴在她的头上。这是通常留给君主本人的王冠。所以这是一个特殊的荣誉。所以这个特殊荣誉的原因，大概是因为现在对每个人来说都很明显了。如果她在12月就知道自己怀孕了，那么现在每个人都一定很清楚她正在期待一个孩子。普遍的假设是，这将会是一个儿子，尽管这个假设没有任何根据。嗯，所以，我的意思是，她被描述为贞洁的绝佳形象，但她也被描述为身怀六甲。所以你是对的，这次怀孕让亨利感到安心。太棒了。
I now have, I have a woman who can give me a son. And if Anne is pregnant with his son, then it's absolutely essential that everything is done to make clear that Anne is legitimately his wife, and therefore his son will legitimately be the heir to the throne. And so it is, on the 26th of August, that Anne Berlin, now the Queen of England, retires to her birthing chamber in Greenwich, and on the 7th of September, she goes into labour. Rakey, well, as we know, the results of this will be a little bit of a disappointment for Henry, and we will return after the break to find out how he deals with it. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you
我现在有了一个能为我生儿子的女人。如果安妮怀的是他的儿子，那么绝对有必要采取一切措施，明确安妮是他的合法妻子，因此他的儿子将合法地成为王位继承人。于是，8月26日，现在是英国王后的安妮·博林退到了她在格林威治的产房，9月7日，她开始分娩。雷基，嗯，正如我们所知，这对亨利来说结果会有点令人失望，休息后我们将回来看看他是如何处理这件事的。本集由Uber赞助。现在，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候出现的那种感觉吗？
when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Welcome back to the rest of history.
我们有时都需要那样，Uber知道这一点。Uber不仅仅是乘车或送餐。无论发生什么，它都会出现。就像为了你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者事竟成，我们在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。欢迎回到历史的其余部分。
So, Amber Lynn, she's just been crowned Queen of England, all kinds of exciting political and theological developments going on in the back. background. She has gone into labor. She has been delivered of a child. Brilliant news. It is an air at last for Henry VIII. And it is a boy. Oh, no, it's actually not. It's the girl. What a massive letdown. So here's the thing. You would think that Henry would be furious and this would be, you know, curtains for Amberlin. And lots of people probably think, well, it is. But it isn't straight away, right? He doesn't completely give up on Amberlin after this. I mean, he's a, I'm about to say he's a reasonable man. I mean, in many ways he's not. But he must recognize as a 50-50 chance that it would
所以，安妮·博林，她刚刚被加冕为英国王后，背景中发生着各种令人兴奋的政治和神学发展。她已经开始分娩。她生下了一个孩子。好消息。亨利八世终于有了继承人。是个男孩。哦，不，其实不是。是个女孩。真是巨大的失望。所以事情是这样的。你可能会认为亨利会大发雷霆，这对安妮·博林来说意味着结束。很多人可能认为，嗯，确实如此。但并不是马上，对吧？他并没有在这之后完全放弃安妮·博林。我的意思是，我正要说他是一个讲道理的人。我的意思是，在很多方面他不是。但他一定认识到，生女孩的几率是50-50。
have been a girl. He's disappointed, but he is disappointed. But also, you know, Anne's had a successful pregnancy. The baby's healthy. There's every prospect that she'll get pregnant again and give him a son. And also, he now has a legitimate princess. So that's better than nothing. And so he's, you know, he in no way repudiates his baby daughter. He kind of shows her all kinds of marks of favour. So her name, the name he gives her Elizabeth, and amazingly, Anne had wanted to call her Mary to erase Princess Mary from the, you know, from the ledger. And Henry says, no, I'm not, that's, that's, that's poor.
他很失望，但他确实很失望。但同时，你知道，安妮经历了一次成功的怀孕。婴儿很健康。她很有可能再次怀孕并为他生下一个儿子。而且，他现在有了一位合法的公主。所以这总比没有好。所以他，你知道，他绝没有否认他的女婴。他给了她各种各样的恩宠标志。所以她的名字，他给她的名字伊丽莎白，令人惊讶的是，安妮本来想叫她玛丽，以从账簿上抹去玛丽公主的名字。亨利说，不，我不会，那，那，那太糟糕了。
So, but he chooses Elizabeth because it's a tribute to his mother, Elizabeth of York. Elizabeth is then baptized in Greenwich. The mayor of London is rowed down there with 40 of the city's worthies, you know, kind of moves and shakers. Elizabeth doesn't get Francis I first, the King of France as Godfather, which she would have done had she been a boy. But she does get Thomas Cranmer. And, you know, Archbishop of Canterby, that's not bad. And of course, the Archbishop of Canterby also is all, you know, it's a kind of imprimatur of legitimacy. Suggests that God is saying she's not a bastard. So that's great. Then after the baptism, which Henry and Anne are not at it. That's not the custom. She's brought out. So Eustace, the imperial ambassador, who's a very hostile witness to Anne. He describes what happens, that a herald in front of the church door proclaimed her princess of England. Then in December, it's a very wintry day, drizzle falling on the streets of London. She rides with splendid ceremony through the capital, out of it, onwards towards the house that Henry has decided will be her official residence.
所以，但他选择了伊丽莎白，因为这是对他母亲约克的伊丽莎白的致敬。伊丽莎白随后在格林威治受洗。伦敦市长带着40位城市名流，你知道，那种大人物，划船去了那里。伊丽莎白没有得到法国国王弗朗索瓦一世作为教父，如果她是男孩的话，她本可以得到的。但她确实得到了托马斯·克兰麦。而且，你知道，坎特伯雷大主教，那也不错。当然，坎特伯雷大主教也是，你知道，这是一种合法性的认可。暗示上帝在说她不是私生子。所以那太棒了。洗礼之后，亨利和安妮没有参加。那不是习俗。她被带了出来。所以尤斯塔斯，那位对安妮怀有敌意的帝国大使，他描述了发生的事情，教堂门前的一位传令官宣布她是英国公主。然后到了12月，那是一个非常寒冷的日子，伦敦街头下着毛毛细雨。她带着盛大的仪式穿过首都，离开那里，前往亨利决定作为她正式住所的房子。
And this is a palace called Hatfield. And it lies 20 miles north of London in rural Hertfordshire. and it's close to the capital, so easy for Henry to visit it, but it's also less likely to be swept by plague, which is always a consideration. So he's looking out for her, and it's a pretty impressive place for a born-month-old baby girl to have. So it's got a great hall, it's got fine apartments,
这是一个叫哈特菲尔德的宫殿。它位于伦敦以北20英里的赫特福德郡乡村。它离首都很近，所以亨利很容易去探望，但它也不太可能受到瘟疫的影响，这总是一个考虑因素。所以他在照顾她，对于一个刚出生几个月的女婴来说，这是一个相当令人印象深刻的地方。所以它有一个大厅，有精致的公寓，
it's got apartment full of deer. You know, it's a palace fit for a princess, I guess. Yeah. So Henry, he goes to visit her, doesn't he, in January, and by which point it's very clear that if there were any question about her parents, which there hasn't been. I mean, she looks a little bit of Henry because she's even got the red hair, hasn't she?
它有一个满是鹿的公寓。你知道，我想这是一座适合公主的宫殿。是的。所以亨利，他去探望她了，不是吗，在一月份，到那时很明显，如果关于她的父母有任何疑问的话，其实并没有。我的意思是，她看起来有点像亨利，因为她甚至有红头发，不是吗？
Yes, and the violent temper, apparently. Right. I mean, to be fair, she's a baby. I mean, that's pretty much the standard. And then the key thing in March, Parliament passes legislation that declares Elizabeth as Henry's heir. But there is a couple of twists, aren't there?
是的，还有暴躁的脾气，显然。对。我的意思是，公平地说，她是个婴儿。我的意思是，这基本上是标准。然后关键的事情是在三月，议会通过了立法，宣布伊丽莎白为亨利的继承人。但有几个转折，不是吗？
So basically, if Henry dies before Elizabeth reaches the age of majority, then Anne will be regent and absolute governor of children and of the kingdom. But also, if you call anybody but Anne and Elizabeth, queen or princess, so the obvious target here is her half-sister, Mary, then that is high treason. And you can say goodbye to your head. Yeah. So great news for Anne, but terrible news for Mary, Henry's daughter by Catherine of Aragon, who is now very publicly and by Act of Parliament declared a bastard.
所以基本上，如果亨利在伊丽莎白达到成年年龄之前去世，那么安妮将是摄政王，是孩子和王国的绝对统治者。但同时，如果你称呼安妮和伊丽莎白以外的任何人，为王后或公主，那么显而易见的目标是她同父异母的姐姐玛丽，那么这就是大逆不道。你可以和你的头说再见了。是的。所以这对安妮来说是好消息，但对玛丽来说是可怕的消息，亨利与阿拉贡的凯瑟琳所生的女儿，她现在非常公开地被议会法案宣布为私生子。
And Anne is ecstatic about this because she detests Catherine of Aragon and she particularly detests Mary and is consistently vicious towards her. I mean, horrible to poor Mary. Can I say something actually on this front? There are some admirable things about Anne. You know, I like the fact that she's acerbic
安妮对此欣喜若狂，因为她厌恶阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，她特别厌恶玛丽，并且一直对她非常恶毒。我的意思是，对可怜的玛丽很糟糕。我能在这方面说点什么吗？安妮有一些令人钦佩的地方。你知道，我喜欢她尖刻的性格
and that she's clever and that she's, you know, a bit of a personality and stuff. But she's horrible. she's horrible to Mary, isn't she, in a way that she didn't have to be? Yeah, and I think in part it's jealousy of Mary's lineage. I think she's jealous on behalf of her own daughter. But it's also in large part because Mary refuses to acknowledge her own bastardy. She refuses to play the game that Henry, her father, wants her to play.
而且她很聪明，而且她，你知道，有点个性之类的。但她很可怕。她对玛丽很可怕，不是吗，以一种她不必那样做的方式？是的，我认为部分原因是嫉妒玛丽的血统。我认为她是在为自己的女儿嫉妒。但很大程度上也是因为玛丽拒绝承认自己的私生身份。她拒绝玩亨利，她父亲，想要她玩的游戏。
And so Anne goes all out to try and erase the privileged status that Mary had previously enjoyed as Henry's eldest daughter. So on the 1st of October 1533, which was only two months after Elizabeth's birth, Henry had summoned Mary and told you are no longer going to be a princess. From this point on, you're just going to be the lady Mary. And Mary understandably burst into tears. She's only 17 years old. I mean, you know, for a teenager, teenagers hate. I mean, it's the most humiliating thing, yeah, basically. The following month, Shapoie reported an even greater humiliation.
所以安妮竭尽全力试图抹去玛丽以前作为亨利长女所享有的特权地位。因此，在1533年10月1日，也就是伊丽莎白出生仅两个月后，亨利召见了玛丽，并告诉她你不再是公主了。从现在开始，你只是玛丽小姐。玛丽可以理解地泪流满面。她只有17岁。我的意思是，你知道，对于一个青少年来说，青少年讨厌。我的意思是，这是最羞辱人的事情，是的，基本上。次月，查普伊斯报告了更大的羞辱。
So he writes, The King, not satisfied with having taken away the name entitled Princess from Mary, has just given out that in order to subdue the spirit of the princess, he will deprive her of all her people because they put notions into her head and stop her from obeying him and that she should come and live as ladies made with the little bastard. The little bastard is Elizabeth. So, I mean, what a humiliation.
所以他写道，国王，对剥夺玛丽公主的名字和头衔还不满意，刚刚宣布为了征服公主的精神，他将剥夺她所有的人，因为他们把想法塞进她的脑子里，阻止她服从他，她应该去和那个小私生子一起做侍女。那个小私生子就是伊丽莎白。所以，我的意思是，多么大的羞辱。
You know, you're stripped of all your own servants and you have to go and work as a servant for your, you know, this girl who's replaced you. I mean, it's absolutely terrible. So Mary is sent there only with two attendants and she's obdurate in refusing to accept this. She says, I'm not going to accept, you know, this horrible little girl as a legitimate heir. She insists she knew no other princess in England except herself. And Anne is so infuriated that she takes away, you know, all Mary's jewels. It's like kind of confiscating her iPhone or something. And she tells the women supervising Mary to box her ears as a cursed bastard.
你知道，你被剥夺了所有的仆人，你必须去为你，你知道，这个取代你的女孩做仆人。我的意思是，这绝对太可怕了。所以玛丽只带着两个侍从被送到那里，她顽固地拒绝接受这一点。她说，我不会接受，你知道，这个可怕的小女孩作为合法的继承人。她坚持说她除了自己以外不承认英国有其他公主。安妮非常愤怒，以至于她拿走了，你知道，玛丽所有的珠宝。这就像没收她的iPhone一样。她告诉监督玛丽的妇女们打她的耳光，称她为该死的私生子。
So Nicola Talis, who wrote another great book, Young Elizabeth, Princess Prisoner Queen. She says, Little Wonder, Mary spent much of her time weeping in her chamber. Yeah, but that makes Mary sound like a drip, whereas Mary's not a drip. I like Mary. I think she has massive, she's got massive backbone, Mary. She obviously, she's regarded as one of the great villains of English history because she lets herself down with the Catholicism. However, she has tremendous guts, I think, and she's a massive survivor.
所以尼古拉·塔利斯，写了另一本伟大的书《年轻的伊丽莎白，公主、囚犯、女王》。她说，难怪玛丽大部分时间都在她的房间里哭泣。是的，但这让玛丽听起来像个软弱的人，而玛丽并不是软弱的人。我喜欢玛丽。我认为她有巨大的，她有巨大的骨气，玛丽。她显然，她被认为是英国历史上伟大的反派之一，因为她因为天主教而让自己失望。然而，我认为她有巨大的胆量，她是一个巨大的幸存者。
You see, I don't think that it's Mordland weeping. I think it's angry weeping. Yeah, I respect that. It's, I hate you all kind of, weeping. That's what it's like. And obviously, none of this makes Anne Eni, the more popular. because we've said how Catherine is very popular with the mass of the English people. And so Anne going out of her way to insult Catherine's daughter, Mary, who's also very popular,
你看，我不认为那是软弱的哭泣。我认为那是愤怒的哭泣。是的，我尊重这一点。那是，我恨你们所有人那种，哭泣。这就是它的样子。显然，这一切并没有让安妮更受欢迎。因为我们已经说过凯瑟琳在英国大众中是多么受欢迎。所以安妮不遗余力地侮辱凯瑟琳的女儿玛丽，她也非常受欢迎，
it doesn't go down well at all. And Chappuiz, unsurprisingly, completely agrees with this. It says, I do not understand why the king is in such haste to treat the Princess Mary in this way, if it were not for the impotunity and malignity of the lady, i.e. Anne. I know he's biased, but he's not wrong. Yeah, he's right. Now, I guess none of this would have mattered had Elizabeth been a boy. I mean, Anne could have done then, in that case, she could have done whatever she liked.
这根本不受欢迎。查普伊斯，不出所料，完全同意这一点。他说，我不明白为什么国王如此急于以这种方式对待玛丽公主，如果不是因为那个女士，即安妮，的无礼和恶意。我知道他有偏见，但他没有错。是的，他是对的。现在，我想如果伊丽莎白是个男孩，这一切都不会重要。我的意思是，安妮本可以那样做，在这种情况下，她可以做任何她想做的事。
Nor if in the wake of Elizabeth's birth, she had then been able to get pregnant again and give Henry the son that she wanted. But this does not happen because in the summer of 1534, absolute disaster. Anne loses a baby. It's gone almost a full term. And the rumor is that it had been a boy. another year goes by and there are rumors of another miscarriage. And it is clear as well to people that Henry is getting a little bit fed up with Anne. So you said you like her.
如果伊丽莎白出生后，她能够再次怀孕并给亨利他想要的儿子，也不会有事。但这并没有发生，因为在1534年夏天，绝对的灾难。安妮失去了孩子。几乎足月了。传言说那是个男孩。又过了一年，有传言说又流产了。人们也很清楚亨利对安妮有点厌倦了。所以你说你喜欢她。
She's sassy. She's a surbic. But Henry, you know, he might, begin with, he might have found that quite attractive, quite titillating. But I think by this point, he's starting to find her bossy, arrogant, nagging, shrewish. And these are not qualities that he's particularly looking for in a wife. Do you know what? Sometimes Anne Boleyn, I said she was horrible, but sometimes she reminds me a tiny bit of myself.
她很时髦。她很尖刻。但亨利，你知道，他可能，开始时，他可能觉得那很有吸引力，很刺激。但我认为到这个时候，他开始觉得她爱发号施令、傲慢、唠叨、泼妇。这些并不是他在妻子身上特别寻找的品质。你知道吗？有时安妮·博林，我说她很可怕，但有时她让我想起了一点点我自己。
Really? Imagine, well, God, Henry would have been lucky to get married to you. There has to be said, Dominic, but the odds of you giving Henry a son would be low, I think. Yeah. It's not a situation I've ever really pondered. Like, how would I perform as Henry, one of Henry the Eighth's wives? But actually, I think probably,
真的吗？想象一下，好吧，天哪，亨利能娶到你真是幸运。必须说，多米尼克，你给亨利生儿子的几率很低，我想。是的。这不是我真正考虑过的情况。就像，我会如何表现为亨利，亨利八世的妻子之一？但实际上，我想可能，
although Anne Boleyn is the one I leak, I like Least. She's probably the one I'm most like. Well, fortunately for you, you are not having to get pregnant by Henry. So that's Anne's job. And ominously for Anne, by this point, Henry, his eye is starting to stray again. He's starting to have affairs. And as early as October 1534, so this is a few months after Anne's second miscarriage, Shapois is reporting that Henry is paying particular attention to one lady in waiting.
虽然安妮·博林是我最不喜欢的。她可能是我最像的人。好吧，幸运的是，你不需要怀上亨利的孩子。所以那是安妮的工作。对安妮来说不祥的是，到这个时候，亨利的目光又开始游离了。他开始有外遇了。早在1534年10月，也就是安妮第二次流产几个月后，查普伊斯就报告说亨利正在特别关注一位侍女。
And this is a woman called Jane Seymour. And the following summer, so that's in 1535, Henry pays a visit to the Seymour house, which is in Wiltshire, I'm delighted to say. Oh, it's great to have Walsh in the Salisbury area back on the show. This is a place called Wolf Hall. So it seems that Henry is really quite keen on Jane Seymour if he's going off and, you know, meeting their parents and that kind of thing. It's unclear exactly what it is that Jane has that Henry finds so irresistible. So Chappui famously describes her as an enigma. She's modest.
这是一个叫简·西摩的女人。次年夏天，也就是1535年，亨利访问了西摩家，我很高兴地说，它在威尔特郡。哦，很高兴索尔兹伯里地区的威尔士人回到节目中。这是一个叫沃尔夫霍尔的地方。所以看起来亨利确实非常喜欢简·西摩，如果他要去，你知道，见他们的父母之类的话。目前还不清楚简到底有什么让亨利觉得如此不可抗拒。所以查普伊斯著名地形容她是一个谜。她很谦虚。
She's not particularly attractive. Chappui describes her as not a woman of great wit. Tracy Borman in her book on Amber Lynn points out that enigma was Tudor slang for the female genitals. So perhaps Chappuie is hinting at something there unclear. But there's one definite advantage that Jane does have over Anne, certainly in Henry's eyes, which is that she isn't always losing her temper with him. But the point about the appeal of Jane Seymour is surely that Amperlin is a surbic, is argumentative, is a bit of a nag, is a bit bossy, all of these things that make her very
她不是特别有吸引力。查普伊斯形容她不是一个很有智慧的女人。特蕾西·博曼在她关于安妮·博林的书指出，谜是都铎王朝对女性生殖器的俚语。所以也许查普伊斯在那里暗示了一些不清楚的事情。但简确实有一个比安妮明确的优势，至少在亨利的眼里，那就是她不会总是对他发脾气。但关于简·西摩吸引力的重点肯定是安妮·博林尖刻、好争论、有点唠叨、有点爱发号施令，所有这些让她非常
interesting. Jane Seymour is quite boring, but she basically is a people-pleaser. Everything we know about her is she's a massive people-pleaser, and she, Henry thinks, God, she's sweet. She's nice. She'll bring me a, yeah, she'll bring me a cup of scented wine or whatever and, you know, nurse my ulcer. She'll find my friends amusing. Exactly, exactly.
有趣的事情。简·西摩很无聊，但她基本上是一个讨好者。我们所知道的关于她的一切都是她是一个巨大的讨好者，她，亨利想，天哪，她很甜。她很好。她会给我带一，是的，她会给我带一杯香酒之类的，你知道，照顾我的溃疡。她会觉得我的朋友很有趣。完全正确，完全正确。
Yeah. But it's still not all over for Anne. So by January 1536, she's pregnant again. And then on the 7th of January 1536, even better news, it is announced that Catherine of Aragon is dead. And Henry's reaction is, God be praised, Anne's brother, George, it was a pity the princess, i.e. Mary, did not keep company with her. So, I mean, really venomous, really venomous. And you might wonder, well, you know, why this hostility? I think for George Berlin, the hostility to Mary is, it's not just dynastic. He, like Anne, has become a very, very passionate evangelical. So we're kind of be anachronistic to call him a Protestant, but that's basically what he is by now.
是的。但这对安妮来说仍然没有结束。所以到1536年1月，她又怀孕了。然后1536年1月7日，更好的消息是，宣布阿拉贡的凯瑟琳去世了。亨利的反应是，感谢上帝，安妮的兄弟，乔治，真可惜公主，即玛丽，没有和她在一起。所以，我的意思是，真的很恶毒，真的很恶毒。你可能会想，嗯，你知道，为什么会有这种敌意？我认为对于乔治·博林来说，对玛丽的敌意，不仅仅是王朝的。他，像安妮一样，已经成为一个非常、非常热情的福音派。所以我们有点时代错误地称他为新教徒，但到目前为止他基本上就是那样。
But Mary, she has stayed very devoutly, very defiantly loyal to the traditional Catholic faith. She, you know, she's loyal to the Pope. And of course, that loyalty is an expression of her loyalty to Catherine of Aragon. So she refuses to accept Henry's supremacy of the church. And this, of course, in turn, then enables her to say, well, I have, you know, I have every godly reason to deny the legitimacy. of my half-sister, you know, baby Elizabeth. And that means that for the Billins and George, you know, the rest of the crowd, their godliness, their evangelical identity is now kind of seamlessly interwoven with their dynastic ambitions
但玛丽，她一直非常虔诚、非常挑衅地忠于传统的天主教信仰。她，你知道，她忠于教皇。当然，这种忠诚是她对阿拉贡的凯瑟琳忠诚的表达。所以她拒绝接受亨利对教会的至高无上。这当然反过来又使她说，好吧，我有，你知道，我有充分的敬虔理由否认我同父异母的妹妹，你知道，婴儿伊丽莎白的合法性。这意味着对于博林一家和乔治，你知道，其余的人群来说，他们的敬虔，他们的福音派身份现在已经与他们的王朝野心无缝交织在一起了
and interests. So for them, it seems obvious that God is on the side of the Belins and against Princess Mary and all these kind of awful Catholics. But of course, I mean, none of this matters. fan can't give Henry what he so desperately wants a son. Yeah. So the clock's ticking. I mentioned his ulcer, actually. I was being anachronistic because he doesn't get this famous ulcer until the 24th of January when he has this jousting accident. He comes very close to death, doesn't he? He's knocked off his horse. People actually think he may have died. And with that, there is a serious, you know,
和利益。所以对他们来说，上帝站在博林一家一边，反对玛丽公主和所有这些可怕的天主教徒似乎是显而易见的。但当然，我的意思是，这一切都不重要。安妮不能给亨利他梦寐以求的儿子。是的。所以时钟在滴答作响。我提到了他的溃疡，其实。我是时代错误的，因为直到1月24日他发生这次比武事故时，他才得了这个著名的溃疡。他差点死了，不是吗？他从马上摔了下来。人们实际上认为他可能已经死了。随之而来的是一个严重的，你知道，
for the first time people think, gosh, he could actually have died. And, and what happens next? You know, the future of the dynasty is not yet secure. There are a lot of people who think when he goes, great, we can get rid of the Tudors.
第一次人们认为，天哪，他真的可能已经死了。然后，接下来会发生什么？你知道，王朝的未来还不稳固。有很多人认为当他走的时候，太好了，我们可以摆脱都铎王朝了。
I mean, they're a bit of an aberration and we can get back to, we can find some plantagenet air to take over. Yeah, we can get back to fighting. Yeah, exactly. Brilliant.
我的意思是，他们有点反常，我们可以回到，我们可以找到一些金雀花王朝的继承人来接管。是的，我们可以回到战斗中去。是的，完全正确。太棒了。
Exactly. So, yeah, and so that fall, it has a kind of knock on consequence because five days later, 29th of January, Catherine Arragon is laid to rest in Peterborough Cathedral.
完全正确。所以，是的，所以那次摔倒，它有一种连锁反应，因为五天后，1月29日，阿拉贡的凯瑟琳被安葬在彼得伯勒大教堂。
and on the same day Anne has a miscarriage and she blames it on the shock that she felt on learning of the news of Henry's fall but Henry thinks no this is the marker of a curse just as my first marriage was cursed so now my second is cursed
同一天安妮流产了，她把它归咎于她在得知亨利摔倒的消息时感到的震惊，但亨利认为不，这是诅咒的标志，就像我的第一次婚姻被诅咒一样，现在我的第二次婚姻也被诅咒了
and he says explicitly I see that God will not give me male children and Shapui you know he is kind of delighted by this, and he writes to Charles the 5th, the emperor, and he reports Henry's growing belief,
他明确表示，我看到上帝不会给我男性后代，而查普伊斯，你知道，他对此感到高兴，他写信给皇帝查理五世，他报告了亨利日益增长的信念，
and I quote Shapley, that he had made this marriage seduced by witchcraft, and for this reason, he considered it null. See, I think Henry, at this point, my sense is that he feels a little bit guilty. Catherine of Errigan has died, and although he
我引用查普伊斯的话，他因为巫术的诱惑而缔结了这段婚姻，因此，他认为它是无效的。看，我认为亨利，在这一点上，我的感觉是他感到有点内疚。阿拉贡的凯瑟琳去世了，虽然他
will never admit it to himself, he has treated her abominably, and she wasn't a bad person. She was a good wife for him, He's treated his own daughter atrociously, and Henry is a very vain man. He will never accept that he's behaved badly. So he pins all this on Anne, doesn't he? Don't you think that's what he's doing? Yeah, I think so.
永远不会对自己承认，他对待她极其恶劣，她不是一个坏人。她是一个好妻子，他对待自己的女儿极其残忍，亨利是一个非常虚荣的人。他永远不会接受自己表现得很糟糕。所以他把这一切都归咎于安妮，不是吗？你不觉得他是在这样做吗？是的，我想是这样。
And I think also what's very unfortunate for Anne is that Jane Seema, although she may be boring, you know, she's learnt from Anne how to play Henry. So in April, Henry sends Jane this purse of gold sovereigns and a letter, presumably, you know, pledging his troth. and she just kisses the letter very demurely and sends it back, unopened, and declares that she will only accept such gifts if she is married. So she's learned from the mistress, how to play, how to do this. That April, the same month, Anne is in Greenwich and she has Elizabeth brought from Hatfield, and Elizabeth by this point is two and a half years old. And Elizabeth has clearly been much on Anne's mind, so Anne has been ordering her all kinds of clothes. It's kind of dresses of orange and purple velvet and taffeta caps adorned with gold, obviously designed to kind of go with
而且我认为对安妮来说非常不幸的是，简·西摩，虽然她可能很无聊，你知道，她从安妮那里学会了如何玩弄亨利。所以四月，亨利送给简这个金索维林钱包和一封信，大概是，你知道，承诺他的誓言。她只是非常端庄地亲吻了这封信，原封不动地退回，并声明只有在结婚时她才会接受这样的礼物。所以她从情妇那里学会了如何玩弄，如何做到这一点。那个四月，同一个月，安妮在格林威治，她让伊丽莎白从哈特菲尔德带过来，到那时伊丽莎白已经两岁半了。伊丽莎白显然一直在安妮的心头，所以安妮一直在为她订购各种衣服。这是一种橙色和紫色的天鹅绒连衣裙，还有装饰着黄金的塔夫绸帽子，显然是为了搭配
her complexion and her urban hair. So Anne again being, you know, the great fashion Easter. And she's clearly worrying, I think, by this point, that Henry might strike against her at any moment. And what are the implications of this for her, for her daughter? So on the 26th of April, she summons her private chaplain for a for a conversation and this chaplain is a man called Matthew Parker who is a very brilliant young evangelical scholar typical of the kind of clergyman that Anne has been favouring and Anne says to him look you know I don't know what's going to happen but suppose the worst does happen please will you promise to look after my daughter Elizabeth and Parker vows yes your majesty I absolutely will and he holds truth
她的肤色和她的头发。所以安妮再次成为，你知道，伟大的时尚达人。她显然很担心，我想，到这个时候，亨利可能会随时对她采取行动。这对她，对她的女儿有什么影响？所以4月26日，她召集她的私人牧师进行了一次谈话，这位牧师是一个叫马修·帕克的人，他是一位非常杰出的年轻福音派学者，典型的安妮一直偏爱的神职人员，安妮对他说，看，你知道，我不知道会发生什么，但假设最坏的情况确实发生了，请你答应照顾我的女儿伊丽莎白，帕克发誓是的，陛下，我绝对会，他信守承诺
to that vow. So years later in Elizabeth's reign, Parker reports the conversation he'd had with Anne at this point to Elizabeth. And he describes it as the last words that ever her majesty's mother spoke to me concerning her. Well, you say the last words because the end is coming for Anne, isn't it? And it comes on, isn't there some story that there, she's watching some form of sport. I can't remember what it is, people playing tennis or something. And then she gets a summons in the council, you know, come and you must come immediately. And she's accused of, to her shock, complete and utter shock, she is accused of adultery. And then she's taken off by barge from Greenwich to the Tower of London.
对那个誓言。所以多年后在伊丽莎白统治时期，帕克向伊丽莎白报告了他当时与安妮的谈话。他将其描述为陛下母亲关于她对我说的最后一句话。嗯，你说最后一句话，因为安妮的末日快到了，不是吗？它发生在，有没有什么故事说那里，她正在观看某种运动。我不记得是什么了，人们打网球之类的。然后她收到了议会的传票，你知道，来，你必须立即来。她被指控，令她震惊的是，完全彻底的震惊，她被指控通奸。然后她被驳船从格林威治带到伦敦塔。
She never even gets the chance to see her daughter before she goes, does she? No, you know, there's no dilly dallying. So after the tower she goes and the boom of cannons announces to London her arrival in the tower. And of course, this was where three years earlier, she'd stayed for a couple of days with Henry in the royal quarters before setting out across London for her coronation, and now she's being incarcerated there as a prisoner. And the first evening that she's there, she asks the constable of the tower, shall I die without justice?
她在去之前甚至没有机会见到她的女儿，不是吗？不，你知道，没有拖延。所以她去了塔楼，大炮的轰鸣声向伦敦宣布了她到达塔楼的消息。当然，这是三年前她和亨利在皇家宿舍住了几天，然后出发穿过伦敦去加冕的地方，现在她作为囚犯被关押在那里。她在那里的第一个晚上，她问塔楼的警长，我会死而没有正义吗？
I mean, she clearly recognizes, you know, the fate that is now threatening her. And the constable replies to her, the poorest subject, the king hath, hath justice, and at this Anne only laughs. and, you know, the laugh after is very bitter because Anne does not receive justice. So she's put on trial on the 15th of May in the Tower of London, isn't she? She's the first Queen of England ever to be subjected
我的意思是，她清楚地认识到，你知道，现在威胁她的命运。警长回答她，国王拥有的最贫穷的臣民，拥有正义，对此安妮只是笑了。而且，你知道，之后的笑声非常苦涩，因为安妮没有得到正义。所以她在5月15日在伦敦塔受审，不是吗？她是英国历史上第一位受到
to a public trial. And the counts, so adultery, she's convicted of adultery with five different men. I mean, they're not messing around. Then the next count, incest, because she's accused of sleeping with her own brother, this evangelical guy, George Berlin, and then treason and conspiracy to kill her husband, to murder her husband. And the thing is, of course, she's obviously innocent of these things, right?
公开审判的女王。所以指控，通奸，她被判与五个不同的男人通奸。我的意思是，他们没有乱来。然后是下一个指控，乱伦，因为她被指控与她自己的兄弟，这个福音派家伙，乔治·博林睡觉，然后是叛国和密谋杀害她的丈夫，谋杀她的丈夫。当然，问题是，她显然是无辜的，对吧？
I mean, people would never, historians don't think she'd plotted against her husband or that she'd slept with her brother or she'd committed, even when she'd committed adultery. No, I don't think any historians think that they're true. essentially Henry wants her eliminated and he's prepared to go to any lengths to do it and sure enough you know the sentences read out to her because thou hast defended against our sovereign the king's grace and committing treason against his person the law of the realm is this that thou shall be burnt here within the Tower of London on the green else to have thy head smitten off and clearly in that it's better to have your head chopped off than to be burnt alive and is being offered a deal
我的意思是，人们永远不会，历史学家不认为她曾密谋反对她的丈夫，或者她曾与她的兄弟睡觉，或者她曾犯下，即使她曾犯下通奸。不，我不认为任何历史学家认为那是真的。本质上亨利想消灭她，他准备不惜一切代价去做，果然，你知道，判决对她宣读，因为你冒犯了我们的主权国王的恩典，并对他的身体犯下叛国罪，王国的法律是这样的，你将在伦敦塔内的草坪上被烧死，否则你的头会被砍掉，显然在这一点上，被砍头比被活活烧死要好，安妮被提供了一笔交易
agree to what I want and you will have a merciful death. And the following day, sure enough, Anne is visited in the tower by Cranma and Cranma wins Anne's consent to the annulment of her marriage. And this might seem surprising to people because effectively, of course, this serves to render Elizabeth now a bastard. But I think Anne is doing it. I mean, partly maybe she thinks, well, you know, I'll have my head chopped off. But I think she thinks that by doing this, her life will be spared, and that will then enable her to, you know, it will ensure that at least Elizabeth will continue to have a mother.
同意我想要的，你就会有一个仁慈的死亡。第二天，果然，安妮在塔楼里受到了克兰麦的探望，克兰麦赢得了安妮对她婚姻无效的同意。这可能对人们来说很奇怪，因为实际上，当然，这导致伊丽莎白现在成了私生子。但我认为安妮正在这样做。我的意思是，部分可能她想，好吧，你知道，我会砍掉我的头。但我认为她认为通过这样做，她的生命会被饶恕，那将使她能够，你知道，它将确保至少伊丽莎白将继续有一个母亲。
But there is no pardon. Interesting point there, actually, Tom, which never really occurred to me, that at that point, Henry the 8th could have pardoned her. I mean, he could have just said send her off, I'd like Catherine of Aragon, send her off to some country house. And then, although people would talk about him as having had lots of wives, his reputation is this. kind of blue beard, who, you know, the wife killer, I mean, he doesn't have to kill her. No, he doesn't. And everyone finds it astonishing. So even Chappui, who obviously hates Anne, I mean, he regards it as madness. So, you know, he says, may God permit that this may be his last folly. It's seen as very aberrant behavior, I think. But, you know, she has now declared
但没有赦免。有趣的一点，其实，汤姆，我从来没有真正想到过，在那一点上，亨利八世本可以赦免她。我的意思是，他本可以只是说把她送走，我想要阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，把她送到某个乡间别墅。然后，虽然人们会谈论他有很多妻子，他的名声是这个。蓝胡子，你知道，杀妻者，我的意思是，他不一定要杀她。不，他不需要。每个人都觉得这令人震惊。所以即使是查普伊斯，他显然讨厌安妮，我的意思是，他认为这是疯狂的。所以，你知道，他说，愿上帝允许这可能是他最后的愚蠢。我认为这被视为非常反常的行为。但是，你知道，她现在已经宣布
and accepted that her marriage was invalid. And so the following morning, 17th of May, in Lambeth Palace. Crammer officially annulls Henry's marriage to Anne. And this means that Elizabeth, like her half-sister Mary, is declared bastard and deprived of the title of Princess. So from this point on, she will be called the Lady Elizabeth. And later that same morning, 17th of May, the five men who've been convicted of adultery with Anne are led out onto Tower Hill. So before the mass of Londoners who've gathered there to watch the spectacle, and one by one they are headed. And George Berlin goes first because he's of the highest rank and the axe will be at its sharpest. So it's a kind of, you know, a measure of privilege there. And he speaks as a martyr
并接受她的婚姻是无效的。所以第二天早上，5月17日，在兰贝斯宫。克兰麦正式宣布亨利与安妮的婚姻无效。这意味着伊丽莎白，像她同父异母的姐姐玛丽一样，被宣布为私生子，并被剥夺了公主的头衔。所以从现在开始，她将被叫作伊丽莎白小姐。那天晚些时候，5月17日，被判与安妮通奸的五名男子被带到塔山。所以在大批聚集在那里观看奇观的伦敦人面前，他们一个接一个地被砍头。乔治·博林先走，因为他的等级最高，斧头会最锋利。所以这是一种，你知道，那里的特权衡量。他作为烈士发言
for his evangelical beliefs. He says, I have been a set of forth of the word of God. So he's implying this is the reason that he's being eliminated. He does not defend his sister. And in fact, only one of the five men who are executed, who's a guy who, Henry, you know, very close to a man called Henry Norris, a long-term favourite and friend of Henry's. He's the only one who does a decent thing and speaks out in defence of Anne. So he said, in his conscience, he thought the queen innocent of these things laid to charge and he would die a thousand deaths rather than ruin an innocent person. But, you know, this has no impact.
因为他的福音派信仰。他说，我一直都在宣扬上帝的话语。所以他暗示这就是他被处决的原因。他没有为他的姐姐辩护。事实上，在被处决的五个人中，只有一个人，亨利，你知道的，亨利·诺里斯，一个亨利长期以来的宠臣和朋友，他是唯一一个做了正确的事并站出来为安妮辩护的人。他说，凭他的良心，他认为王后对于这些指控是无辜的，他宁愿死一千次也不愿毁掉一个无辜的人。但是，你知道，这没有任何影响。
It doesn't help Anne. And on the 19th of May, so two days later, it is her turn to meet death. Now, she does not die, as the five men accused of adultery had done on Tower Hill, but within the tower itself. So there's a measure of privacy. A thousand people are gathered to watch it, but she doesn't have the stinking rabble, jeering and mocking her.
这对安妮没有帮助。5月19日，也就是两天后，轮到她面对死亡了。她并没有像那五个被指控通奸的男人那样在塔丘上被处决，而是在塔内。所以这有一定的私密性。有一千人聚集观看，但她没有受到那些臭名昭著的暴民的嘲笑和侮辱。
A great scaffold has been erected next to the white tower. It's been draped in black. She approaches it wearing a grey silk gown. She's led to the scaffold. She climbs its steps, and then she addresses the crowd. And she says, I pray God save the king
白塔旁边搭建了一个巨大的脚手架。它被黑布覆盖。她穿着一件灰色丝绸长袍走近它。她被带到脚手架上。她爬上台阶，然后向人群发表讲话。她说，我祈求上帝保佑国王，
and send him long to reign over you for a gentler nor a more merciful prince was there never. I mean, obviously she doesn't believe this. And so people may wonder, well, why would she say it? And I think that, you know, the reason is, is that she is hoping it will encourage Henry to look more fondly on their daughter. And so it may well be that, you know, in her final moments, Anne's thoughts are of Elizabeth. So there isn't a block. She just kneels in the straw. She says her prayers and then she removes the hood that she's had. And so that kind of opens up her neck. Her hair is bundled up, put in a cap.
并让他长久地统治你们，因为再也没有比他更温和、更仁慈的君主了。我的意思是，显然她并不相信这一点。所以人们可能会想，她为什么要这么说？我认为，原因在于她希望这能鼓励亨利更疼爱他们的女儿。所以很有可能，在她生命的最后时刻，安妮想的是伊丽莎白。所以没有断头台。她只是跪在稻草上。她做了祈祷，然后摘下了她戴的头巾。这露出了她的脖子。她的头发被束起来，塞进了一顶帽子里。
So her neck is now absolutely exposed. Lady in waiting step forwards, blindfolds her, and leans forwards. She's still saying her prayers. And then there's a French swordsman who Henry has especially hired for his expertise, kind of slight mark of mercy, I suppose. And he quietly reaches down for his sword without making a sound. So Anne doesn't know when it's going to come. and then with very smooth, very silent precision,
所以她的脖子现在完全暴露了。侍女走上前，蒙住她的眼睛，然后向前倾身。她还在祈祷。然后，亨利专门聘请了一位法国剑客，因为他的专业技术，我想这算是一种小小的仁慈。他悄无声息地伸手去拿他的剑，没有发出任何声音。所以安妮不知道什么时候会发生。然后，以非常平稳、非常安静的精确度，
he brings the blade of the sword down onto Anne's neck. Her head is severed with a single blow, and before her execution had said that she had a little neck, so there's no kind of hacking and chopping at it. It's done very efficiently, and the head is then held up to the crowd, and it's reported that her mouth continues to move in prayer for several seconds after her decapitation.
他将剑刃挥向安妮的脖子。她的头被一剑砍下，在行刑前她曾说她有一个细长的脖子，所以没有那种砍剁的过程。行刑非常高效，然后头颅被举向人群，据报道，在她被斩首后的几秒钟内，她的嘴还在继续做祈祷状。
Gosh, I wonder if that really happened. Well, I think it is possible. I mean, the whole question of what, happens to you after your head is chopped off is a very interesting one. And I gather much contested. Right. Okay. Who knows? You know, there are markers of mercy, the French swordsman. She hasn't been burnt to death. It's been in privacy. But it's still completely shocking. And I think that Henry's willingness to sanction the judicial murder of his queen, of Henry Norris is, you know, one of his closest friends, four other presumably innocent people
天哪，我不知道那是否真的发生了。嗯，我认为是有可能的。我的意思是，关于你被砍头后会发生什么的问题是一个非常有趣的问题。据我所知，这很有争议。好吧，谁知道呢？你知道，有一些仁慈的迹象，比如那位法国剑客。她没有被活活烧死。行刑是在私下进行的。但这仍然令人震惊。我认为亨利愿意批准对他自己的王后、亨利·诺里斯（他最亲密的朋友之一）以及其他四名大概是无辜的人进行司法谋杀，
as well. It speaks of his utter resolve to secure this great prize that he's been longing for, which is a son. So on the 30th of May, he marries Jane Seymour. And a year and a half later, on the 12th of October 1537, she dies, but she has done what Henry married her for. So two weeks before her death, she had given him the male heir that he had been so, so desperate to obtain. and it's a boy called Edward. But where does that leave Elizabeth? Because Elizabeth, Tom, is now being declared illegitimate. She's a bastard and she's the daughter of somebody who's basically been erased from the annals as a traitor and as an adulterous and as a witch.
这说明了他为了获得他一直渴望的那个大奖——一个儿子——的坚定决心。所以5月30日，他娶了简·西摩。一年半后，即1537年10月12日，她去世了，但她已经完成了亨利娶她的目的。在她去世前两周，她为他生下了他一直渴望得到的男性继承人。那是一个叫爱德华的男孩。但这让伊丽莎白处于什么境地呢？因为伊丽莎白，汤姆，现在被宣布为私生女。她是一个杂种，是一个基本上被从史册中抹去的人的女儿，被视为叛徒、通奸者和女巫。
So where will this lead? Well, the good news is if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can find out right away, And you can hear the rest of the episodes in this series, including the next one, which explores how the young Elizabeth survives the murderous snake pit of the court of Henry VIII. And of course, if you're not a member of the Restis History Club and you want to hear the whole of the series right now, you can join our very own snake pit, our very own murderous Tudor court, at the restis history.com. So wonderful news for everybody. Tom, that was absolutely brilliant. Thank you very much for that. A tour de force. And we'll see you all next time. Bye. Bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么这会导致什么呢？好吧，好消息是，如果你是Restis历史俱乐部的成员，你可以立即找到答案。你可以收听本系列的其他剧集，包括下一集，它探讨了年轻的伊丽莎白是如何在亨利八世宫廷的致命蛇窝中幸存下来的。当然，如果你不是Restis历史俱乐部的成员，并且想现在就收听整个系列，你可以在restis history.com加入我们自己的蛇窝，我们自己的都铎王朝谋杀宫廷。这对每个人来说都是个好消息。汤姆，这太精彩了。非常感谢你。这是一次杰作。我们下次再见。再见。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。